Speaker 1: Speaker of the House Kevin
McCarthy has been asked to weigh in
about the looming charges against the
failed former President Donald Trump
and when he was given the opportunity to weigh in.
He mentioned Hillary Clinton. I know. I know. It
seems it seems impossible. They're not it's not
they're not doing it again, are they? Yes. Kevin
McCarthy brought up Hillary Clinton. I'm almost
ready to declare that Hillary Clinton must pay for
the crimes of Donald Trump. Why not? Right. Hold
her accountable. Here is the speaker of the House.
Speaker 3: About the investigation
that there are three short stories
yesterday into the prosecutor from New York
raised a lot of concerns about the prosecutor.
But what about the actual allegations here
that the former president may have falsified?
Speaker 1: This is Manu Raju from CNN. By the way.
Speaker 3: Business refers to cover for hush money
payments to cover up this alleged affair with
an adult film actress. Do you have any concerns
about this?
Speaker 4:
Look, the thing I think about it was
interesting, somewhat somewhat brief me on
the use of money, a situation like this before.
And you probably covered this. Remember when
the DNC and Hillary Clinton I hate the law firm
$1,000,000, but and said that it was for something
else. And we found out later it wasn't. It was.
Speaker 1: Wait a second, Kevin, That doesn't
sound like you're answering the question.
Speaker 4: About the Russia collusion. It
wasn't for a legal part. And so they went through
and they got investigated $1,000,000 they spent.
And you know what? At the end of the day, they
didn't get prosecuted. They got fined. Hillary's
campaign got fined $8,000 and the DNC got fined
$100,000, even though they used $1,000,000.
They knowingly hid the fact of what they were
doing to try to hide. They got investigated.
So I look at it from this perspective place we
live in America that should be equal justice.
This was personal money. What I'm
trying to hide. This was seven years
ago. Statute of limitation. And I think
in your heart of hearts, you know, too,
that you think this is just political. And
I think that's what the rest of the country
thinks. And we're kind of tired of that.
Speaker 1: Understand that Kevin McCarthy
gives a 92nd answer about a minute. If it took
28, 20 or so seconds to ask the question. He
gives about a minute answer. The question is about
the looming arrest and indictment of a president.
And all he talks about is Hillary Clinton. You
have to hand it to him. He's been trained pretty
damn well deflect, deny and distract. When it
comes to Donald Trump and his criminal actions
and the is it gaslighting? A couple people wrote
to me and said, David, this this is essentially
gaslighting. That's that's what Kevin McCarthy
is doing here. He's gaslighting the media. Well,
yeah, it's an attempt at gaslighting, but it's a
very transparent one. And I don't know that this
is going to work. I don't know that people are
necessarily going going to be going for this. And
it's particularly ironic that Kevin McCarthy says,
well, we want equal justice. If it's one thing
for a Republican, then it's another thing for a
Democrat. But you know that Kevin McCarthy doesn't
actually want equal justice, or at least his party
doesn't when it comes to actually trying to create
equal situations where we say, well, the
rich and the poor are treated differently
by the justice system, we should equalize that.
Now, they don't actually care about that. Well,
we're seeing dramatically different outcomes in
all sorts of different measures of attainment
based on whether people live by no fault of their
own in poor versus wealthy neighborhoods. Let's do
something about that. Now, that sounds like woke
nonsense. They want equality when it's convenient
for them and then otherwise they go equality.
That's just that woke nonsense that you guys
won't stop talking about. So Kevin McCarthy, it
took them a few days to be ready with the talking
points, but it's all Hillary Clinton all the time
and we'll break down. I mean, I do think. I'm of
two minds. On the one hand, if I spend a lot of
time myself talking about how the Hillary Clinton
situation he references was very different.
I'm sort they're kind of winning, right,
Because I start talking about Hillary. At the same
time, it might be worth doing a run through of the
Hillary Clinton situation he's talking about
and why it is so dramatically different from
what Trump is embroiled in right now. Let me
know in the comments. Should I do that segment
about how the Hillary situation is different or
should I ignore it altogether? Because exactly
what they want is for people talking about
Hillary Clinton instead of Donald Trump. Let
me know in the comments and I'm at your mercy,
Whatever it is you want me to do, I will do.